this a kind of start there you know he
this is third game he's been ejected in
um how how problematic is not having him
on the floor B for you guys early this
season we always say about our team like
all the pieces fit for a reason they
have for a very long time so when you're
missing one it uh it's tough we still
had opportunities you know to win the
game tonight um you know I didn't shoot
the ball well in the second
half we obviously mixed up lineups and
we're trying to find some chemistry our
bench played
amazing again
so you know you want to be able to
overcome the uh the incident and his
ejection but we just weren't able to get
it done but we need everybody available
that's how we're built it's no secret to
Our Success if you said the other day
about you you guys can't talk about it
anymore you just got to be about these
changes does the same apply to to
Draymond even though he said it wasn't
it wasn't an intentional act to not put
himself in those positions anymore where
the margin is that he gets
ejected yeah that's the challenge
because I we always told him you can't
change who you are as a player and you
know the competitive spirit that you
have um the physicality that you play
with um but you can't give people people
reasons to lead reasons to look at you a
certain way
um and to have to go you know judge and
jury every single incident that happens
so it's it's tough because we need him
out there and obviously the ejection um
change the M momentum or the emotions of
the
game um but that's going to be his
challenge you know and we're here to
support him here to have confidence in
him to be able to do that
and uh yeah because we we obviously need
him to win changed up his rotation
tonight obviously you know you had three
more starters on the bench in closing
time did you feel like it was time to to
do that I mean that's a coach we said
from the jump begin of the Season coach
has to coaches knowing the options that
we have and he's talked about playing
guys that are you know playing playing
the best and giving us the best shot and
I know he's had some regrets earlier in
the year with individual games but you
know tonight we really didn't have much
going
so um you they're going to be tough
decisions that's the nature of this
business and nature of um you know
trying to sustain this level of
winning that doesn't mean you lose
confidence in anybody it's just you know
the results are what they are and you
have to you you know be be realistic
about the the things that need to change
to get us where we uh where we want to
be but it's still going to involve
everybody so
um tonight was an indication of
that